there's no point denying that harrison
ford has long been considered the
resident grump of the star wars ensemble
he's known to be a bit grouchy towards
the franchise that gave him his first
big break into movie stardom he's even
gone so far as to repeatedly mention how
he wished for han solo to get killed off
at some point apparently he simply
doesn't like playing han solo and would
prefer to take on more three-dimensional
characters in the vein of rick deckard
from blade runner but unless you've been
vigilant in reading every scrap of
information you can about ford and his
co-stars on the set of the original star
wars movies you might not be familiar
with a tidbit dropped by one mark hamill
during a 2015 interview about his
memories of working with harrison ford
on the films before we go on it's
probably a good idea to point out that
hamel's feelings toward ford seem to be
uniformly and mutually positive in an
interview with jake's takes from
february of 2020 ford returned the favor
by saying something quite nice about his
jedi comrade in arms when i met mark
hamill i really learned how to be cool
he's just a really straightforward nice
guy he's really a sweet guy but hamill
has shared at least one star wars memory
that shows ford could be somewhat
volatile on set in a 2015 interview with
empire mark hamill shared a funny story
about an incident involving harrison
ford and han solo's iconic spaceship
you've heard about harrison taking a saw
to the millennium falcon because he got
so mad people were coming up to me going
you gotta stop harrison he's sawing up
the falcon it was made of wood and he
just took a saw to it hamill didn't
share exactly what ford was mad about
when he decided to make such unorthodox
use of his skills as a carpenter but he
did share that he was able to bring
things to a peaceful resolution i love
harrison i got to stop him because i can
make him laugh when he gets really
really mad and i had no stake in it he
was with carrie and i was still hanging
out with yoda the yoda reference is a
clue that the incident in question
happened during filming of the empire
strikes back fortunately hamill was
there to comfort down in production of
what many fans considered to be the
masterpiece of the entire star wars saga
proceeded to its eventual creative and
commercial success
given the stories like the one hamill
shared it'd be easy to assume ford is a
grump all day every day however
considering his career has spanned
several decades at this point across
numerous different franchises one has to
assume people enjoy working with him to
an extent after all no matter how good
of an actor you are a bad attitude is a
surefire way to sink any career no
matter what your name is fortunately it
appears ford knows when to cut loose and
have fun in the same empire interview
hamill goes on to tell a story of how
ford knows when to be silly as well
hamill goes on to relate he's got a
wonderfully wacky sense of humor i'll
give you an example this disco song that
goes more more more how do you like it
how do you like it remember that we used
to love really bad pop songs so whenever
that song would come on i'd run and turn
it on and he'd come into my dressing
room and start dancing you aren't alone
if you're having a difficult time
envisioning harrison ford dancing along
to disco songs as it turns out there's a
good reason for that the minute somebody
comes to the door he'd stop dead and
stand there yeah okay i'll be down to
the set in a minute as soon as the door
closes it's get the action going he'd
only do it around me it sounds as though
ford and hamill have a special bond and
there's a specific image ford wants
emitted to the general public still we'd
give anything to see that footage of
four dancing along to andrea
true check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite actors are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]
you